this Bible belonged to a German soldier
during the First World War it literally
saved his life when his shelter was
bombed and four centimeter long piece of
shrapnel came to be lodged there he it's
just one out of 1,500 original objects
hand-picked from 35 countries to be part
of a new transnational History Museum
opening this week in Brussels quarter in
Java 2016 11 vientiane start a normal
person knowing nats analysis on danse
avec Giga is an ecosystem hope a strain
on China's field vendetta's language is
exactly identical
amenda suit us secreting on the muslim
self within the sphere of appeared to
run Google the brainchild of the
Parliament former president the health
of European history tanks visitors from
the French Revolution up to today
showcasing times of war as well as peace
meant as a place for debate the museum
did not claim to define European
identity the line today is we need to
debate me to discuss and to study and to
know our history our seventh years of
freedom and peace I think it's important
the spiral at the building's heart sets
the tone history is in flux depending on
how you look at it
[Music]